hello and welcome to our virtual event
bioprocess next Leadership Summit in
Expo 2022 we are kicking off today with
a live interview between Daniella cramp
from thermal Fisher Scientific and
former FDA commissioner Dr Scott
Gottlieb Daniela who is senior vice
president and president of the
bioproduction business at Thermo Fisher
we'll interview Scott to learn more
about the evolving opportunities in the
bio manufacturing Market Daniella's
experience spans the Health Care system
from dealing with complex hospitals and
Health Systems to working with physician
practices retail health and at-home
patients she holds a bachelor's degree
from the University of California
Riverside in an MBA from University of
California Irvine
Scott is a physician and served as the
23rd commissioner of the U.S Food and
Drug Administration Scott's work focuses
on advancing Public Health through
developing and implementing Innovative
approaches to improving medical outcomes
reshaping Healthcare delivery and
expanding consumer choice and safety he
serves on the board of Pfizer and
Illumina is a resident fellow at the
American Enterprise Institute a partner
at the Venture Capital firm new
Enterprise Associates and a CNBC
contributor Scott is also the author of
The New York Times best-selling book
uncontrolled
covid-19 crushed Us and how we can
defeat the next pandemic this life
interview
will highlight his perspective on
Lessons Learned From the pandemic and
its impact on the Biotech Industry today
and in the future before we begin I'd
like to encourage you to engage with us
you can submit questions at any time
during the interview simply type them
into the Q a box and click Send we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the conversation
please help me welcome Dr Scott Gottlieb
and Danielle Grant
thank you Molly and Scott welcome it's a
pleasure to have you with us today thank
you so much for taking time out of your
busy schedule to be with us thanks a lot
thanks for having me so last year we
were still in the middle of this
pandemic when we spoke and the big
topics were around vaccine distribution
and Global disparities there our very
rapid regulatory clearance of these
vaccines and and how we were going to
really start to vaccinate the population
now that we seem to be entering an
endemic phase we want to focus the
conversation today on the lessons
learned and the path forward beyond the
pandemic period so to get our
conversation started today
I'd like to ask you you know looking at
the current market situation from your
perspective how do you think the
recovery phase is going as it relates to
the pharmaceutical industry outside of
covid-19 and moving from vaccines to
Therapeutics how do you see that
Evolution at this point
look I don't think that the um the
pandemic had as dramatic of an impact on
the pharmaceutical sector as many feared
at the outset and there was a lot of
concern that there would be dislocations
in the supply chain that would create
drug shortages particularly since a lot
of the starting with chemicals for a lot
of API was made in uh in China and Wuhan
in particular and I think that there was
a lot of concern that clinical trials
would be disrupted and be hard to start
new clinical trials there definitely was
some impact on ongoing clinical
development clinical trials but a lot of
companies were able to make
modifications to those trials to keep
them going a lot of companies were able
to continue to enroll and start new
clinical trials and say in the pandemic
adopting some new tools for doing that
um Reliance on you know site instead of
site-based Raiders Reliance on data
collected at home shipping drug to
patients they could self-administer it
under um you know witnessed Telehealth
visits using real world evidence to
supplement missing data in clinical
trials things like that a lot of
clinical trial Innovation that had been
perkling for a while I think allowed
things to continue so you didn't see the
major dislocation that I think some
feared at the outset of the pandemic and
against this backdrop look we've seen
remarkable progress in in science it
allows us to understand the fundamental
biological basis of more disease it's
very rare these days that a drug is put
into development where you don't
understand a very clear rationale for
why it would work at a molecular level
in the intervention of a disease years
ago we used to screen uh targets against
large compound libraries and we would
get a find a compound in a big library
that hit at Target and would put it
understanding how it was working to
intervene in a particular disease
mechanism now those kinds of uh
development programs are rare uh not not
putting a drug into development where
you don't really have a clear
understanding of its mechanistic basis
is rare and in fact I wouldn't say it's
a requirement for the regulatory process
but it's certainly preferred when you're
coming through drug development inside
the agency if you have a very clear
rationale and why your drug would work
and so just you know the greater insight
into biology of disease has opened up a
vast New Opportunities the last organ
really to be drug where we're still
making some fundamental biological
insights we've seen very rapid
um you know rapid evolution is the brain
I think we're going to see a lot of
opportunities to treat intractable brain
diseases both mental health as well as
neurogenic diseases that so far have
eluded us or not been amenable to really
effective therapies and so there's a lot
of opportunities there and then the
final point I'll make and I know we're
going to touch on this probably
um it's just the opportunities in
selling gene therapy I think continued
product Innovation coming up with better
platforms for developing cells and Gene
therapies is opening up a whole new
opportunity set with respect to those
those modalities as well
I couldn't agree with you more very
excited about the prospect there and
selling gene therapy tell me a little
bit about how you see mRNA evolving as a
modality I mean it was the modality of
the moment during the pandemic no
question about it how do you see us
leveraging that as an industry as we go
forward
well look clearly
um it looks very effective as a platform
for vaccines I'm going to border Pfizer
as you mentioned which has made um the
code vaccines developing other vaccines
off that mRNA platform so is moderna and
so are other companies for that matter
so I think mRNA has demonstrated to be a
very effective platform for vaccines and
you know there's some qualities about it
that make it uh uniquely attractive one
is that the MRNA itself the MRNA
component seems to be immunogenic so it
actually you know up regulates or
stimulates the immune system so an mRNA
vaccine in some ways is auto adjuvanted
if you look at the other the
protein-based vaccines that have been
put into development for example for
covid they all contain novel azurons
people sort of talk about the
protein-based vaccines as if they're you
know sort of old technology they have
very novel technology in them
um in terms of the the adirons that they
used with the MRNA vaccines you don't
have an edge run included because in
many respects the MRNA itself is
creating some up regulation some
stimulation immune system at the same
time that you're delivering the energy
in the form of mRNA that gets converted
into protein so I think that these are
going to be attractive for other vaccine
settings first and foremost and in
particular one of the things that was
striking about the data around the MRNA
vaccine I remember the first time I was
shown the data uh you know the data from
the Pfizer vaccine was shown to the
board the thing that was most striking
was the consistency of the efficacy
result in that initial data set you know
you saw you saw literally as you went
down sort of segments of Ages by by 10
years you had a very consistent result
and typically as you know with vaccines
you don't see that and typically you see
a falloff in efficacy
um especially among an older population
and you didn't see that here and so it
does raise the possibility I think it's
becoming more than a possibility this
this platform may be you know uniquely
suited to trying to provide
immunogenicity to an older individual uh
whereas traditional platforms you don't
see as good of a response we usually
have to use large doses in older
individuals this platform seems to be
particularly well suited to those
settings and the other thing the other
obvious Advantage is just the ability to
go from
um you know an antigen to a to a vaccine
very quickly by using the MRNA sequence
and the ability to put in the syringe
things that might not be stable so for
example with the flu vaccine one one of
the reasons why this platform is
attractive for the potential creation of
an influenza vaccine in fact Pfizer had
a flu program with their mRNA platform
before they pivoted into developing
covert is that our flu our flu vaccine
each year is made uh based on one
antigen so there's two immunodominant
epitopes on the influenza virus um
H A and N A and the the so they're both
proteins on the surface of the virus the
vaccine that we get every year only has
one of those proteins in it the reason
why both proteins aren't included is
because one's unstable it's hard to get
it in a syringe and keep it stable so
you're only getting immunized against
one of the immunodominant epitopes with
influenza every year when you use sort
of a protein-based recombinant vaccine
with mRNA you're not you don't have to
put the protein in the syringe so if the
protein is unstable that's not a problem
what you're putting in the syringe is
the MRNA sequence that codes for the
protein so with the MRNA platform you
can actually get both of those
immunodominant epitopes into the into
the syringe and you can potentially
vaccinate against both both proteins on
the surface of the influenza which might
provide better efficacy might provide
better durability for the flu vaccine so
there's things you can do with mRNA that
you can't do with traditional vaccines
and in the final point I would just make
is that the other advantages
you can go from you know sort of
identification of the you know the the
virus to production of a vaccine very
quickly because you don't have to figure
out how to
um scale the grow the virus itself in a
Cell culture
um and that's been a rate limiting step
in the past particularly with novel
viruses and that's why this vaccine
platform I think is uniquely attractive
for
um pandemic strange novel viruses where
the first step would be to try to grow
it in a Cell culture here you could you
could potentially sidestep that
complexity and then the final the final
final point I'm sorry is you know this
is a platform that was being used to try
to develop Therapeutics and I think
those opportunities are still going to
be very accessible modern was pursuing
oncology
um targets with this platform Pfizer was
looking at therapeutic applications so
it's not just going to be used in my
view in the future for uh developing
vaccines I think you're going to see the
ability to deliver mRNA that then codes
for production proteins being used as a
way to deliver therapy either on a sort
of you know episodic basis or or for you
know routine Administration I think this
platform is going to open up a lot of
possibilities
it's exciting and how do you see and
witness the balance right now between
focus on the next pandemic and pandemic
preparedness and then other therapeutic
areas of Interest as you talked about
earlier you know the brain being another
area of focus for the future how do you
see the balance between between the
pandemic and and just future
Therapeutics and the prospect of those
in general
hey look I I don't see an ordinate focus
on
um you know pandemic preparedness and
and
um
you know developing cover therapeutic
certainly not in a way that it's uh
preoccupied the activities of a large
swath of the industry and and even the
companies that are engaged in it I mean
Pfizer you know is obviously broadly
involved in a lot of other activities
through the pandemic this has been a
tremendous Focus but it hasn't stopped
work on other therapeutic priorities I
you know I I say that with a little bit
of chagrin sort of broadly that there
hasn't been this focus on pandemic
preparedness more broadly I don't think
you've seen
um Congress sort of contemplate what
what is the future of preparedness
posture that we need what kinds of
Investments should we be making and
keeping a hot base of preparedness for
future contingencies
um you know what kind of preparedness
should we have if covert takes some
unexpected twists and turns are we going
to be able to scale up the manufacturing
of Novel monoclonal and antibodies and
get them approved through a very
expedited regulatory process have we
really created a framework for the rapid
adaptation of the vaccine if this should
undergo some unexpected changes very
quickly I don't think a lot of that's
been done quite frankly we're sort of
three years into this uh and all those
kind of points that I just raised about
do we have this in place do we have that
in place we don't um and it's more of a
it's more of a policy issue I think the
industry is in a good posture to be able
to respond quickly I think we haven't
really firmed up some of the policy
considerations that we need to to have
good uh good preparedness but with
respect to the you know the other
aspects of the industry's portfolio the
non-covet aspects of the industry's
portfolio as they said the outset I
think that there has been you know
certainly has been tremendous Capital
that's flowed into biotech and Life
Sciences over the last couple of years I
think there has been significant
progress you haven't seen a real drop
off in drug approvals you haven't seen a
drop off a substantial drop off in drug
development a lot of clinical trials I
said work you know continued a lot of
site-based clinical trials continue
particularly in oncology in areas like
that and so you didn't see the major
disruptions your contingency Capital
flows you continue to see a lot of a
scientific innovation that's going to
lead to I think future drug development
in areas that we haven't been able to
drug in the past
great I
comments later on on some of the
infrastructure that you you made earlier
but coming back to the biotech
investment area actually a great segue
to another question what are you most
excited about there in terms of the
Investments that are coming in the space
and what you're seeing what are you
witnessing what what excites you most
about the Biotech Industry and the
investment areas there look I think that
there are some fundamental insights into
um immuno oncology that's going to allow
the Therapeutics in that space to to
hopefully be far more effective I think
we've kind of
um hit a point where we recognize that
there is some missing aspects to our
understanding the biology of intervening
um in the immune system as a tool for
combating cancer we've had we had sort
of tremendous breakthroughs with the
pdl1 and pd1 Inhibitors and then we've
had some challenges trying to
um attack solid tumors with those
approaches and um you know improve the
efficacy of the existing drugs and I
think that they're they're if you look
at the literature there are been some
recent insights into those mechanisms
that things like the pity1 Inhibitors
Target where there may be opportunities
to create Therapeutics that could be a
substantial improvement over the
existing therapy I think we've kind of
reached a point where was trying to make
some fundamental insights and there was
a sense that we're missing something
we're not we're not recognizing
something and I think that something is
starting to get recognized the other big
area that I would just point to is just
selling gene therapy which I touched on
um you know there I think that the the
significant opportunities are going to
come from product Innovations the
ability to develop better platforms for
manufacturing cells for getting Gene
cassettes into cells to to manipulate uh
the the genetic instruction set in cells
things like the improving upon things
like the aav vector finding better
platforms for delivering larger Gene
cassettes
um you know if you think about it I the
the analogy I give is to monoclonal
antibodies if you think back to like the
early 2000s or late 1990s I was at FDA
in the early 2000s working as a senior
advisor to the commissioner and what I
often say is that if someone would have
said to me back then
that one day we'll be using monoclonal
antibodies to treat high cholesterol and
Asthma I would have thought that that
was completely insane because back then
you know monoclonal antibodies were
therapeutic antibodies were a relatively
uncertain modality we couldn't
characterize them well as you change the
manufacturing process things would
happen to the
um to the
antibodies that would produce that would
change their clinical profile and FDA
didn't know didn't know how to discern
that we didn't have the tools for
looking at antibodies and looking at
their structural features and saying
that two things were were similar and so
the and they were also murian you know
the the original antibodies remember
were partly based on on Mouse grafts so
they they had a lot of side effects
associated with them and they weren't
some of them weren't that effective the
early ones so they were reserved for
third line therapy they reserved for you
know sort of third line cancer and and
um more devastating conditions but then
you saw a lot of product Innovation you
saw the Advent of the fully humanized
antibody the abgenics and metorex mouse
the ability to really characterize them
very well and now antibodies are a
routine part of clinical care they're
used for Primary Care conditions I think
that the same thing is going to happen
with cell and gene therapy right now we
think of gene therapy as something
that's reserved for you know pediatric
devastating pediatric inheritive
disorders and rare diseases
um and the same thing to some degree
with cell therapies where they're where
they're being developed I think as you
get more product Innovation more
Innovation and how those products are
manufactured how they're delivered
you're going to see greater certainty
about their clinical profile greater
certainty about the durability of the
treatment greater certainty about the
ability to prevent off-target effects to
get the right insertions
um
yield's going to go up you know when you
transfect cells and put in a new new
Gene instruction set you're going to get
better processes if you're doing that
and yields are going to go up costs are
going to go down and as all those things
happen as you get that product
Innovation I think that the
um the range of therapeutic applications
is going to expand dramatically as you
get sort of Greater certainty around the
safety profile and the costs come down
that's going to happen you know we look
at people sort of look at the market
today the gene therapy market and look
at how expensive these therapies are the
reality is the cost of goods are
exorbitant in these therapies and so I'm
not well I'm not arguing that there's
not a significant margin on these
therapies and companies that are
manufacturing them in most cases I mean
some cases they're not but in most cases
they're able to do it profitably
um it's only been able to be done
profitably because the prices are so
high and that's creating a lot of
complexities in terms of how they're
paid for
those prices are going to come down and
so I think people who sort of in a
policy realm who kind of bemoan the cost
of these drugs and and you hear a lot of
in Washington I'm in Washington today
people talking I'm gonna be on Capitol
Hill tomorrow people talk about you know
how is the system going to afford this
this is going to bankrupt the system I
think it um takes for granted how much
product Innovation is going to happen
very rapidly that's going to change the
economics um I remember hearing the
story about the first the predecessor to
rituxin by idec
um the first anti-city 20 drug that they
had made it was basically a bespoke drug
the CEO described it to me I I can't
fully relate the story I forgotten a lot
of it but it was basically like a
bespoke drug that was manufactured for
each individual patient and if I
remember correctly it costs like 40 or
50 000 of dose and this was back in you
know the mid 90s
um so it was just it wasn't a viable
commercial product even though it looked
very effective and it wasn't until they
had some product innovations that
they're able to manufacture this at
scale and not do it on an individual
draw these patient basis that they were
able to actually develop a commercial
product same thing's going to happen in
cell and gene therapy you know right now
many of these products are very bespoke
very patient specific but I think you're
going to have opportunities to have
off-the-shelf products that's really
going to change the game
what a great Prospect for patients and
patient care worldwide to have that
opportunity let's switch gears for a
minute we were talking about costs and
costs of therapy let's talk a little bit
about inflation and the impact that
plays in this segment of Market how do
you think inflation is going to play out
in the biopharma industry and when you
think about it do you think it's going
to change the context of how we think
about biosimilars in in that regard
yeah look this has been a segment that's
been plagued by
um higher inflation for a long time
um you know regulatory costs have gone
up far faster than the cost of than the
ability to reprice products in this
market
um I think the challenge is you're
seeing costs continue to go up and a lot
of the costs in drug development are
being driven by the um regulatory costs
increasing regulatory costs and the
ability to take price increases is being
eroded so you know whereas you looked
historically companies would take
increases year over year and it was sort
of a stepwise fashion in terms of how
price increases would be taken under in
the injectable space and especially
space to sort of correlate with ASP plus
six percent every company took their
five percent price increase each year
it's becoming much harder to do that to
to raise the um the the real price and
in fact uh real prices have come down
list prices you know have gone up not
nearly as dramatically as they have in
past years but the actual real price on
average average paid for drugs has gone
down because you're seeing compression
of the rebating and you're seeing more
discipline around less price increases
by companies because it's hard to take a
list price increase on drugs there's a
it's not just hard to push it through
the commercial segment but um there's a
lot of political scrutiny paid to
companies and so they're very I think
they're very aware of making sure
they're not taking price increases I
don't know uh going to capture a lot of
attention so that's going to be pressure
I don't know that the the environment
um that we're in right now where you're
seeing inflation across the economy
really changes the equation for
companies I mean it's going to obviously
have an impact and add more pressure on
top of pressures that already existed
but I'm not sure that's going to really
change the equation of the dynamic of
the company that the industry's been
under for some time and the biggest
pricing biggest price inflation I think
that's going to impact the industry is
uh is around Personnel you're seeing the
industry do things in my view to change
the model in ways that could be more
cost effective I think you're seeing
companies on particularly large
companies but across the board companies
change how they sell products
um how they how they detail Physicians
how they interact with Physicians using
more virtual interactions that's going
to cut down on costs you're seeing
companies bring more of the development
work in-house I think with the hope of
getting better control over it and
execution and maybe bringing down costs
so you know whereas in the past a lot of
the
um a lot of the development work was
outsourced to cros and a lot of the
commercial aspects of the Enterprise
were were done in-house I think you're
seeing a little bit of a switch where a
lot of the commercial work is being
externalized using virtual platforms and
other kinds of selling models and a lot
of the development work is being brought
in-house and I think that that's driven
to some degree by by the cost pressures
and probably you know the biggest place
you're going to see the the cost
pressures potentially play out is on the
r d budgets I think that you know
companies are going to scrutinize very
carefully the p l hit of the continued r
d and that's not to say that investments
in r d are going to go down but I think
you're going to have to see company
you're going to see companies probably
take costs out of other aspects of the
business to be able to maintain the very
large r d budgets that
um that most companies maintain
thanks for that
and sort of On a related note
um one of the other burning platforms
last year we talked about was supply
chain and in fact I'd say you know as
much as many of us hoped that would
actually improve in the last year I
think it's it's just intensified some of
our challenges there what are you seeing
now as you think about the supply chain
and the the Pharma industry what are you
hearing what are you seeing and
observing there as we think about
getting back to a more steady state
hey look I I I'm seeing and it's
anecdotal improvements in the ability of
source materials I I think that
um we're getting back to you know a
little bit more of a state and supply
chain and away from some of the shocks
that we saw as a result of the pandemic
um China is still a big uncertainty uh I
think that I don't see what the end game
is for the Chinese government in terms
of controlling covid I don't think in
the age of Omicron you can adopt a zero
covered policy more it's going to be
impossible to keep Omicron out
um unless they adopt very drastic
measures which is what they did in
Shanghai but I don't my view is that the
kinds of lockdowns that they impose in
Shanghai aren't sustainable and you
can't just Implement them on a rolling
basis when you have outbreaks the end
game to me would be to make more
widespread use of effective vaccines the
Chinese government has access to vaccine
platforms that could be and probably
would be more effective against Omicron
they've made a decision so far not to
deploy them they also have a population
that while the overall vaccination
statistics look reasonably good relative
to other countries it's skewed very
young and so the older population tries
the exact opposite of what you'd want
the older population is largely
unvaccinated or under vaccinated not
boosted not vaccinated because 52
million people over the age of 80 who
haven't been vaccinated at all the
booster rate is only around 50 for those
over the age of 65. so they have a under
vaccinated older population I don't know
why I've asked people why that is some
have speculated as more mistrust among
the older population of the government
more cultural mistrust and so you've
seen more of a reluctance to use the
vaccine among the older versus the
younger population but that creates a
lot of vulnerability and I think that
you know future Supply disruptions
probably are you know in the cards
because of future disruptions inside
China and and a maintenance of a zero
covered policy in an age when I think
it's going to be impossible to do that
and the other piece of this just the
broader supply chain question is I think
that the pandemic has created an
awareness
of the vulnerability of having
um a supply chain that's very far flung
um that relies on materials from lots of
other different countries
some in parts of the world that there
may be more political uncertainty uh so
I think that you're seeing a movement
generally towards trying to bring more
of the supply chain uh to domestic
production to domestic facilities and
get better control over very long lines
of Supply you know whereas starting
materials come from sources in one
country and then intermediates are made
in another country and then fill
finishing is done in another country
trying to get more control over that and
trying to make sure less of it is
dependent upon parts of the world that
are a little uncertain I think to some
degree that means a lot of companies are
looking at their supply chain going
through China and there's going to be I
think a rethinking of that and an effort
to try to bring more of the production
to domestic uh you know sources and you
saw in the in the padufa package that
was proposed in the house last week
the creation of a category of advanced
manufacturing technology and the
creation of a policy mechanism that
gives preferential treatment to products
that are developed on what what's
considered Advanced manufacturing
platforms and so that is basically a nod
to things like continuous manufacturing
um and having sophisticated
um biologics manufacturing located using
height developed using high technology
platforms that could be high-tech low
footprint and so low labor where those
there would be sort of um there'd be an
advantage to locate them domestically so
if you think of a continuous
manufacturing platform for small
molecule Pharmaceuticals that's a a
small footprint high-tech platform I
mean I I saw those I toured them and a
lot of the language in the house bill
was geared towards this kind of a
Innovation that's something that you
would you might want to locate in
downtown Boston not not necessarily
um overseas because before you might
have located your Manufacturing overseas
because you were trying to capture lower
labor costs in some cases lower energy
costs but if you're dealing with a
platform that doesn't require a lot of
labor but it's very sophisticated and
high tech requires a lot of skilled
Personnel to operate that's something
that you'd probably want to locate uh
you know domestically or you know maybe
in the UK someplace like that so I think
that this is going to drive a lot of or
create opportunities to bring a lot of
manufacturing back to domestic sources
the other big input obviously for
manufacturing is energy and it you know
we we in many respects have lower energy
costs in other parts of the world right
now where products were manufactured so
I think some of the advantage of
manufacturing overseas are going to be
eroded by advances in technology and the
house bill was clearly an effort to try
to accelerate that I mean I was there
when we made the initial proposals to
get money in fda's budget for those for
trying to develop regulatory processes
to promote the um the migration onto
these Advanced manufacturing Platforms
in both the cell and gene therapy space
as well as the small molecule space and
the language in the house bill basically
adopts that so it's very clear that
that's part it's a continuation of the
same process at least in my view
excellent and Switching gears for a
minute from resource constraints and and
costs to now resource preservation let
me ask you you talked about energy a
minute ago how are you viewing
sustainability as as a priority relative
to all the other Dynamics in the
industry at this point what are you
seeing and how do you think it's going
to evolve
yeah look it's it's clearly a priority
um of the companies that I'm familiar
with that I interact with I think
you know one place where you see a lot
of effort being made is on the um the
environmental footprint of the of the
men of the industry a lot of the biggest
environmental impact from the industry
is through the manufacturing process and
I think you're seeing an effort to try
to
uh make those processes more green lower
the carbon output from traditional
manufacturing and that's another reason
why I think more of this could
potentially move out of the places where
manufacturing has traditionally been
done I think there's going to be an
effort to get more control of the supply
chain there's going to be an effort
there's going to be some National
Security considerations around where
products are manufactured and making
sure they have they're done in in parts
of the world where you can have a
reliable source but there's also going
to be an effort to adopt Technologies
um that make them less impact make those
processes less impactful to the
environment and I think that's going to
be better done in places like the United
States than places where some some
manufacturing institutions have been
done like China and India so I think
that that's going to be another Factor
Weighing on decisions to change where
manufacturing is done now obviously a
lot of this is also a lot of fill
finishing and a lot of the work is also
done based on where
um you know what what based on what the
tax treatment is in different
jurisdictions but you're seeing
International laws change around that
too where I think that there's less
advantage to manufacturing one
jurisdiction over another especially
giving somebody is offsetting
considerations
great thank you for that
one of the other areas that was really
exciting during the pandemic
speed of regulatory approval and the
regulatory response during the pandemic
do you think regulatory entities are
going to now recalibrate to ensure you
know more rigor in the process for
biomanufacturers how do you think about
that
yeah you know I don't have a view that
they ever
um
you know became lacked in terms of the
rigor or the regulatory process I think
that there were definitely
accommodations made
um for some of the things that you
weren't able to do during uh during a
pandemic so you couldn't do on-site and
inspections of manufacturing facilities
you had missing data and clinical trials
that you needed to find constructs using
real world evidence to try to compensate
for missing data in clinical trials you
needed to decentralize clinical trials
because you couldn't bring patients into
site-based
um you know site-based Raiders and and
into hospitals and physician offices for
purposes of monitoring them so you had
to move some of the monitoring to the
home do data collection directly from a
patient so I think that you're going to
see a continuation of those kinds of
Innovations
um but that to me that wasn't really
making the regulatory process more lacks
uh or more permissive I think it was
just accommodations for what you
couldn't do in a setting of a pandemic
and I think what the agency's been able
to demonstrate and what has learned is
some of this some of these work quite
well and what the industry has learned
is some of these work quite well you can
lower costs you can expand enrollment
you can move clinical trials to
non-traditional venues you can get more
diversity into clinical trials when
you're not
held to only enrolling in brick and
mortar physical sites when you can
enroll people virtually so I think
people have found a lot of these work
quite well and you're going to see a
continuation of them so I never really
saw anything that I would say was
um you know FDA becoming much more
permissive in terms of what what it
would allow or level of uncertainty
would Embrace clearly the setting where
that
um you know where there was some truth
to that was in the setting of the uh the
emergency use authorizations and and
trying to get products to the market
rapidly on um
small complements of data but you know
even there I think that they they held
those products to a pretty high standard
especially in a setting of an emergency
and and where the accommodations were
made under the eoa process wasn't
um necessarily on the requirements
around clinical data I mean look how
long it took FDA to approve REM death
severe they waited for the readout of
the randomized trial the NIH trial and
and the British trial before they made
an approval of that and for the vaccines
they didn't approve authorize the
vaccines initially on an interim
analysis and all the subsequent
authorizations were made on readouts a
pretty robust clinical trials I mean the
initial clinical trials for these
vaccines remember were forty thousand
patient trials collectively probably
over a hundred thousand patients were
enrolled in the initial vaccine trials
largest clinical trials ever undertaken
for any medical product where the
accommodation was made was more on the
CMC side
um and that's what the eua process
allowed because you know instead of
doing the complicated CMC package and
doing all the stability testing to
demonstrate that you know the vaccines
for example take them as an example you
can you know have a shelf life of you
know 16 months and be stored in X
temperature for x amount of time and
then in you know in a refrigerator in a
freezer and that if they went outside
those those temperature constraints they
would still be stable all the things
that you would do when you're putting
something into the normal supply chain
because you know once you put something
into the normal supply chain you know
it's going to sit on a shelf for too
long it's going to be on a truck that
you know breaks down and gets warm and
and things are going to happen so you
want to do a range of uh testing
um stability testing to make sure that
products are durable and they can live
outside very narrow ranges that testing
when these products first came to the
market wasn't done and the reason wasn't
done was because
um that's what the eua allowed you
didn't need the full CMC section to be
completed at the time of the
authorization and you didn't need to
necessarily be as concerned about those
those issues because you knew you were
putting products into the market that
we're going to be tightly distributed
they were going to they're basically
being bought by the government they were
going to be distributed by the
government they were going to be
distributed right away
um you know the initial for a long time
we didn't have enough vaccines
everything that we were producing was
getting used and so you didn't you
didn't have to worry about something
going into normal distribution where you
had a myriad of you know pharmacies and
wholesalers and other intermediaries
Distributing something it was very
tightly controlled so the eua process
allowed the FDA
not to do all the CMC work and a lot of
what What's Happening Now is it going
back and doing these full approvals is
they're doing the long-term stability
test and that's why you're seeing the
companies come out with announcements
that you know we now have data showing
that this can be held in normal
Refrigeration for two months and then in
a normal freezer for X months because
those Studies have been done
um if you would have done those studies
up front we wouldn't have had the
vaccines for another six or eight months
and so the e-way process allowed that
portion of the application not to be
fully complete at the time of the
initial authorization whereas it would
for half for full approval for bla
um but I don't see that as a an
accommodation on the
um the level of you know safety and
efficacy information that FDA required
and I think that this is not not in this
context so not anyone on this call
because we're all familiar with this but
outside this context when you're like on
Twitter when I'm on Twitter debating
people and they say FDA cut a lot of
corners for the authorization of these
vaccines you know my response is no they
did they actually required a new
enormous outcome studies where they made
some accommodation with the initial
authorizations was on the stability
testing because they knew these were
going to be you know put into a tightly
controlled supply chain and distributed
right away so that that that's very
different
um than you know the FDA
creating a whole lot of regulatory
accommodation I I think they actually
um yeah they did on in some respects but
in other respects they really didn't
how do you think about let me ask about
a specific example and you earlier
commented on on how exciting the
technology may be as we think about the
brain and development there I wonder if
you can comment on the developments in
the aav specifically Alzheimer's drug
sector
um I think about Lily's clinical trials
in China and those getting slowed
recently how do you think about that as
it plays into the regulatory landscape
here
well look I it's hard for me to know
exactly what's going on with the
clinical trials in China it's not just
Lily we saw some other
um programs that had to get modified
because they relied
um primarily or exclusively on data
derived from from China you know when I
was at FDA there was um and this is all
public uh there was a
um an amnesty announced inside China
that that anyone who had falsified data
they would they would provide amnesty if
you withdrew it and I remember the
statistic at the time was startling in
terms of the percentage of applications
that were withdrawn from the Chinese FDA
um but it was it was a very high
percentage
um there was a perception and I think
rightfully so that the uh there was
um
you know a lot of uh behaviors over
there that wouldn't meet Western
regulatory standards I'm trying to be uh
polite
and
um but there was also a perception I had
met with the Chinese the head of the
Chinese FDA at the time and you know
they were making a lot of commitments to
really clean up they recognized that
um they had a lot of lacks activities
and they were making significant
commitments to really tighten their own
um regulatory oversight and clean up a
lot of the practices that had been going
on that that we thought had been going
on
um and I you know Rick Paster the heavy
oncology division did a two-week trip to
China toured a lot of clinical trial
sites and Facilities met with a lot of
officials came back
um I remember talking when he came back
felt
um you know fairly confident that there
was a level of earnestness about
um improving the approaches there and
trying to put China on par with uh with
Western Regulatory Agencies and and put
the systems there on par with our our
practices
um and the only thing I could conclude
from the analysis aspects I've seen is
that that has fallen short you know that
that and if you listen to some of the
comments that Rick's made
um you know that that's what I glean
from listening to him knowing where he
was back in 2019 2017 when when we were
sort of struggling with this and and
there was a change in the view of FDA
about data coming out of China and and
the conduct of clinical trials in China
and the regulatory oversight in that
country and hearing
um
a little bit of you know what I can sort
of characterize as buyer's remorse on a
part of some of the FDA officials it's
sounds to me like that's what's happened
like they've had a realization that in
fact
um you know the approaches in China
didn't didn't live up to what was
promised so that's what I surmise based
on not knowing specifically what's going
on not having talked to Rick about it
not being inside the FDA anymore
um but just knowing what I knowing you
know what was said publicly back in
2017-2019 the sentiment and then seeing
the announcements now and and trying to
glean the sentiment off of people's
statements that's what I would
um that's what I was surmise about that
about the context of Trials and I think
you asked me about the Alzheimer's drug
I I you probably were referring to the
reimbursement issue with CMS
um which is you know a whole nother
matter but I think that the um you know
CMS the decision that CMS made around
um around the Biogen product and in
particular
um where they they non-covered it
effectively I mean they've only covered
in clinical trial which is non-coverage
but they went a step further and
basically said part of the basis for
their non-coverage is the fact that that
drug was approved through accelerated
approval so so they basically
um they took they
did did things that were gratuitous in
the context of that coverage decision
that went well beyond just a coverage
decision around their discrete analysis
of the efficacy and safety data for that
particular product but carved out a
whole nother
um
a whole nother Paradigm for themselves
of authority to be able to not uncover
things just by virtue of the uh
regulatory process that they've come
through and that's been something CMS
has long wanted to do but there's been
discipline to prevent the agency from
doing that and I think that this process
lacked discipline and CMS really crossed
a significant line in the context of
this coverage decision and what it means
is that any company coming through
um accelerated approval on a Part B side
that's probably a non-uncletic because I
think CMS is going to be reluctant to
change its coverage criteria at least in
the near term for oncology products and
it's going to be reluctant to do
anything that would deviate from the
nccn compendia around oncology products
at least for the time being but I think
if you're outside oncology with a Part B
drug particularly a drug that's come
through accelerated approval
um I think you're facing a much
different CMS and I think CMS has
basically adopted the kind of approach
that they took to a lot of medical
devices to to the part B drugs now at
least that's what they did with Azure
Helm and the Azure homes decision to me
looked and the the decision around
Alzheimer's products more generally that
Target amyloid
um plaque removal
looks a lot like the tavr decision if
you want sort of a proxy for what CMS
did here look at what they did to the
minimally invasive aortic valve where
they basically only covered that in
certain circumstances where data was
being collected prospectively and then
they put a lot of requirements on how
that product would be delivered
requirements that really weren't
um in my view fully based on
um sound clinical judgment but were
based on a desire to try to control
utilization of that product they only
allowed certain centers to deliver the
product and they based that on a view
that only high volume centers should be
doing it they required cardiac surgeons
and cardiologists to be in a room at the
same time they based that interview that
if something went wrong you want the
cardiac surgeon on site I viewed that as
a an attempt to try to make sure that
you didn't have a Turf War and
competition between Interventional
cardiologists and cardiac surgeons to
implant the procedure which would have
driven up volumes so they wanted to
prevent that so they made sure both
providers had to be in the room at the
same time when the procedures were done
um you know very clever but those were I
think those were attempts to try to
control the commercial use of the
product not necessarily just born of
um clinical judgment I think the
clinical judgment was sort of backed
into them after the fact
um but the primary purpose was was a
commercial prerogative and I think the
same thing we saw the same thing with
with Andrew Hellman with the decision
broadly around the Alzheimer's products
and it's going to have a chilling effect
I think it's it was a profound decision
um the most profound aspects of it I
think were
are parts of it that weren't really
widely recognized and it's often the
case that agencies will make
profound policy
in the context of decisions that are
otherwise politically attractive you
know this was a this was a decision that
was applauded in the media because there
was a sort of
um it got caught up I think in a lot of
political views around accelerated
approval and what criteria companies
should be held to what standard they
should be held to if they're going to
market products that are going to
ultimately end up costing a lot of money
um and so there were a lot of people who
were had a negative view of of this
product and didn't want to see CMS cover
it broadly and I think what you saw with
with the coverage decision is they did
that but they also embedded in a lot of
other policy and they were able to get
away with it because people were sort of
focused on the top line and weren't
focused on the the policy rationale
driving that decision which I think is
very corrosive
okay I have two more questions for you
then we're going to open it up to uh to
the broader audience but this is
probably a question you get asked I
would suspect quite often
um what do you think the future is for
covid-19 how are we going to live with
this in the endemic phase and do you
think we're going to see a fifth booster
what's what's your prediction Scott yeah
look I think this is a transition year
where we're going from sort of a
pandemic phase to an endemic phase and
um I would define an endemic phase is
when this is no longer continuous waves
of infection but it settles into a more
seasonal pattern that doesn't endemic
phase doesn't mean that we're not going
to have a lot of infection and doesn't
mean that we're not necessarily going to
have a lot of death and disease from
this infection but it's going to be more
predictable ways of infection this will
become more of a winter pathogen which
is what a coronavirus should be I think
we're in that transition year right now
I think this summer is going to have low
prevalence levels and as we come back in
the fall we're probably going to be
grappling with one of these new variants
it's most likely going to be a variant
within the Omicron lineage barring
something unexpected happening which is
of course possible because unexpected
things have happened for the last three
years but you know right now the
assumption would be it's either going to
be b b 2.121 which is this train that's
now spreading in New York although it
looks like it's peaked and looks like
it's slowing down in its rate of spread
or B4 B5 which is a normal Crown lineage
that's now spreading in South Africa and
seems to pierce the immunity from prior
infection with B1 with Omicron people
who are unvaccinated so it looks like
it's gonna be one of these variants or
maybe something similar to them and I do
think that we're probably going to be
switching over the vaccine I mean we
need to see the data we haven't yet
um both modern and Pfizer are working on
new new vaccines based on the Omicron
lineage it's based on a B1 strain of the
virus but I think that there was a good
reason to believe based on other
experimental data that being boosted
with uh
um an omocron variant is probably going
to provide better protection against
these new Omicron variants that we're
seeing you certainly sort data out of
South Africa that would suggest that the
Siegel's lab who's very good researcher
looked at reinfections with people with
B4 B5 what they found was that people
who had a normal chronic previous
homicron infection with B1 didn't have
good protection against before B and B5
and in fact there are reinfections
happening in South Africa there was an
Eightfold drop in the titers
neutralizing antibiotitors between
people who had B1 and now were
confronting before B5 so they're they're
antibiotitors that they had from their
B1 infection didn't neutralize B4 b5b
well at all but people who had been
vaccinated and then had a breakthrough
infection with Omicron had pretty robust
protection against B4 B5 and I don't
think it's a huge leap although it's a
leap I will admit it to postulate or to
to sort of speculate that
um that a bivalent vaccine or delivering
you know either 50 omocron 50 of the
ancestral lineage which is one
possibility for the fall or an Omicron
only vaccine delivered as a booster to
the existing vaccine could simulate that
effect it could simulate the effect of a
breakthrough infection where you're
providing targeted
um you know protection against Omicron
on the backbone on the backdrop of
someone who already has Baseline
immunity that's derived from from the
vaccine with the ancestral strain so I
think there's reason to believe that
that an omicron-based vaccine may be a
bivalent vaccine that seems to be some
um view in the policy world that may be
a bivalent vaccine is a way to hedge
your bets because you're getting you
know sort of The Best of Both Worlds
you're getting the targeted protection
against the omocrine lineage but you're
also
um providing a booster against the
ancestral strain which provides the
broadest possible immunity from what
we've seen that that is also going to
provide better protection than the
existing vaccine against these new
Omicron sub lineages that we're seeing
so I so short answer your question is I
think covet's going to be back in the
fall
it's not I don't think that the White
House estimate that they put out in
recent days of of you know speculating
that could be upwards of 100 million
infections it's not crazy if you think
about how many infections you could have
over the course of the whole season you
know we have 30 40 million flu
infections over the course of a whole
season
um a lot of those infections are going
to be very mild and not get reported
they're they modeling that the White
House is using is based on an assumption
that there's not going to be any
mitigation that we're basically back to
normal life which we kind of are right
now I mean I think people have gotten
back to normal routines in-person
meetings in-person events so
um you know you're going to be dependent
upon vaccination and previously acquired
immunity and people who were previously
infected with B1 unless they're
vaccinated will that immunity will have
waned that immunity is not going to be
that durable we've now seen a lot of
evidence that the immunity confirmed by
Omicron isn't as durable as your meeting
conferred by prior strain so you'll have
a whole bunch of people who you know
were never vaccinated but right now have
pretty good durable immunity they're
going to be susceptible again to fall so
they're going to get reinfected you know
and they'll probably be people who are a
little bit more
um maybe a little bit more confident
overconfident because they were
previously infected and they don't think
they're going to get it again and then
you're going to have to mount another
booster campaign
um to deliver vaccines and you're
probably not going to get the same
uptake this time around that you've
gotten in last rounds I think you're
going to do better than what we've
historically done with flu vaccine but
remember in a sort of in our best years
for flu vaccine before covid we would
vaccinate 120 million people that was
considered a really good year I think
the the record was like 130 million
people in one season and that's with
mandated vaccines for children for
influenza
um so you know are you going to do
better with covet I think you certainly
will but are you going to be able to
revaccinate two-thirds of the population
in the fall you might not be able to and
so that's why you know you're going to
see continued spread
very helpful so one final question from
me and then we'll turn it over to the
audience so in your book you highlighted
some of the challenges with the pandemic
response and I'm curious if you could
real quick tell us a little bit about
what you think the two or three
learnings are that we should be heating
as we go forward uh in preparedness for
the next pandemic
hey look I think that the two biggest
learnings were one we don't we thought
we had sort of an agency equipped to
respond to a pandemic and we thought
that agent was a CDC and it wasn't you
know CDC is sort of a deeply
retrospective very academic organization
um they're not a real-time analysis
organization they're not an organization
that can collect data from uh routine
clinical practice and put out uh very
rapid analysis to inform current
decision making they'd rather take six
months and do a morbidity mortality
weekly report and be sort of the final
word on a question rather than the first
word and what you needed was an agency
that was able to respond to a crisis in
a real-time fashion you need the joint
Special Operations Command for health
care for public health and you had like
the Harvard School of Public Health
instead in charge and so I think we need
a different mindset I'm not saying a
different organization because I think
it's a Folly to say let's just create a
new agency that's going to be a pandemic
agency I think this capacity needs to
reside within CDC but it needs to be a
component with agency that has a much
different mindset that has much more of
a national security mindset
um and you need to have the ability to
do
um you know a handoff to Industry to
engage industry very early CDC is sort
of very insular and that's this was
personified with the development of
diagnostic test where CDC didn't partner
that work wouldn't share samples
wouldn't distribute the test outside of
their normal conduits into Public Health
Labs and so you need an agency that will
engage industry right away to do rapid
scale up of the components they're going
to be needed to respond to a pandemic
and that's what South Korea did if you
want to see a model of where you had a
public health agency leading a an
all-of-the-above approach was in South
Korea and they had put in place
mechanisms to work very quickly with
their private industry to scale
production of things like diagnostic
testing that they would need in a crisis
we didn't do that we didn't have those
mechanisms in place that leads me to the
the second point which is that there was
always this notion that we're going to
create a warm warm base of preparedness
they can't tell you how many times I
heard that term when I was in the
government as part of our pandemic
preparedness and the notion was that you
build facilities where you contract with
facilities for capacity and you keep it
warm you know it wouldn't be operating
but you'd be able to scale it up in a
crisis and you'd stockpile a whole bunch
of components and I think what we
learned in the setting of this crisis
and you saw it with emergent and you saw
the news yesterday with the merchant
when an emerging was a big piece of that
sort of warm-based preparedness is that
base needs to be hot needs to be
operating so you need different ways to
kind of contract for what you're going
to need so to take an example with
biologics manufacturing you can't just
build a facility and partially operate
it because you're not gonna be able to
scale it up in a crisis the the
most coveted commodity is the skilled
Personnel to run it and you can't just
make them suddenly magically appear in a
crisis so if you want to have biologics
capacity
in in a setting of a crisis you're going
to need to pay for basically a call
option on someone's existing capacity so
you're going to have to you the
government's gonna have to go out and
say you know what we'll pay
um 100 million dollars a year to be able
to call away 200 liters of biologics
manufacturing capacity on three months
notice for 16 months
maybe it won't sound like that there's
probably people on the phone cringing
right now who are like that doesn't make
sense but something like that you get
the point and and how would that get
filled well maybe regeneron would bid on
that and what they would Regina would
say is you know what instead of building
um three reactors we're going to build
five and we're going to kind of rotate
them and operate all of them instead of
operating them in 80 we're going to
operate them at 50 or they might say you
know what we're going to freeze two
years worth of our API so that if we
need to turn over our entire facility of
the government we can just burn down our
Frozen stock for you know 24 months
um or 12 months whatever it is so
there's different ways to fulfill that
but the point is you have an operating
facility and what the government's
purchasing isn't a facility that's
getting mothballed it's purchasing a
call option on an operating facility on
something with it the Personnel are in
place and it's ready to go so that's a
that's a hot base of preparedness and
that's how we're going to need to think
about pandemic preparedness in the
future we're gonna have to build we're
going to over build some of the critical
capacity I'll give you one more example
and I'll pause
we ran out of PCR testing at the outset
of this crisis I mean no no one ever
envisioned that we'd have a pandemic
with a coronavirus we always thought it
would be a flu in the installed base of
flu tests and doctor's offices would be
sufficient in setting with pandemic flu
suddenly you needed to collect
respiratory samples and do PCR testing
well if you look at the big Labs like
Quest and lab core they'll operate
sophisticated Machinery at 80 capacity
they'll have you know 3 000 machines
running at 80 capacity at a high
complexity lab maybe they should be
running 5 000 machines at 50 capacity so
now they've got some built-in capacity
they've got an operating lab with the
skilled people there to run it but they
have some residual capacity they're not
operating anymore for maximal efficiency
they're operating for maximal resiliency
and they're getting paid to do that
there's a government's Contracting with
them to do that I think those are the
ways we need to think about pandemic
preparedness in the future creating that
hot base and preparedness
thanks for that that's actually a
fascinating perspective and I think one
that probably the industry in general we
constantly struggle and discuss I think
that's really helpful context to be
thinking about extra capacity uh Scott
this has been an incredibly engaging
conversation as always a great pleasure
so I want to thank you for that and I
want to open it up now to Molly to
invite questions from the audience
thank you Scott and Daniella it's been a
great conversation and we only have time
for you know one to two questions from
the audience but
um let me just jump in and uh Scott
outside of the U.S Are there specific
geographies you see focusing on
Innovation within the biopharma industry
and how do you see this impacting the
market both now and in the future
yeah look I I think that there's a lot
of uh Innovation going on all around
um the world and and I think a lot of
different parts of the world are
recognizing that um
building a vibrant life sciences sector
is important for public health reasons
it's important for economic development
so
um I I wouldn't point to any one region
I think that you're seeing a lot of
vibrant activity all around you are
seeing you know one thing I would sort
of take note of is you are seeing more
Venture Capital going into Europe
European life science Ventures and and
you know having been around the Venture
world for 15 years I think there was a
period of time where there was
um a little bit of a reluctance to
invest in in Europe um it was seen that
there was the life science Industry had
sort of downsized there
um and now I think you're seeing
governments invest back in their life
science Industries you've seen critical
mass of
um skilled personnel and and and
Innovation happening countries like the
UK and Germany and other parts of Europe
and now you're seeing more U.S Venture
Capital go back into those that part of
the world so that's that's one thing
that I would take note of
thank you and I think we have time for
one more question
um covid-19 has been evolving quickly
the emergence of new variants has
outpaced our ability to keep up on the
vaccine side even with mRNA vaccines
which can be quickly modified to match
the current dominant variant any ideas
on how we can catch up clinically could
we surrogate markers be used to could
surrogate markers be used to assess
efficacy of vaccines designed to the
latest variant yeah no it's it's a great
question because like if you would if
you were designing a vaccine for the
fall right now would you use B1 or would
you use B2 and you know we could pivot
to a B2 vaccine but uh it would be
dependent upon different regulatory
processes you'd have to be willing to
authorize the vaccine on epidemiological
data and rely Less on clinical data we
have gotten there with the flu vaccine
you know we have a
um an approach where we authorize a flu
vaccine on on serum studies there's no
there's no clinical data generated
because the platforms that we use for
the flu vaccine are so well understood
and it's so well understood how
immunogenicity demonstrated against
serum it correlates to a clinical
response I think we can get there where
we could uh pivot very quickly to a new
vaccine more quickly than we we are
today and the MRNA platforms allow for
that and and sort of Plug and Play
manufacturing so it allows for scaling
up manufacturing very quickly you don't
have to figure out how to grow a new
strain in a Cell culture you just kind
of plug a new cassette in and all the
manufacturing capacity that you've
you've created can be used to Pivot to a
new vaccine I don't think the policy
constructs are quite there yet
um but I think we'll get there because
you know the if you see if you look at
the progression of what FDA has done is
very methodical it's very thoughtful and
it has allowed for more accommodation as
we've gotten more clinical certainty
about the performance of these vaccines
so I think we'll get there I think we'll
probably I won't be there for this year
like if you wanted to Pivot to a B2
vaccine right now I think that that
would be sort of a late season product
you'd still probably deploy the B1
vaccines in in September and then maybe
later in the winter if the 2.121 becomes
a dominant strain the existing vaccines
don't cover it quite as well as you want
maybe a B2 Focus vaccine becomes a
product that's used in a high-risk
population or something like that I mean
that's a possibility but I don't think
that the regulatory
process is going to be
sufficiently accommodative to allow us
to Pivot right now I think what I think
what we're going to be contemplating
right now is the vaccines that we've
been prepping which is The Ones based on
B1
thank you so much we've run out of time
but um thank you again Scott and
Daniella for a wonderful and very
informative conversation
um thanks for the participation from the
audience as well don't forget to
navigate the event platform and visit
the exhibit hall poster Hall and virtual
labs when you have a chance the next
presentation is starting now and will
feature Philip proverb from CPI talking
about the past present and the future of
mRNA manufacturing so don't miss it
thanks for your time and enjoy the rest
of the event